and she is in studio Christian your
student begim first of all
congratulations welcome back to the
studio this was not an easy game did she
surprise you in the opening when she
allowed this uh morazzi
buy hi guys it's good to be back yes
absolutely she surprised me she never
plays C5 so I didn't even look at uh
that line for some reason and I was like
okay let's just play and obviously I
didn't get anything out of the opening
well the moroi Bine is always uh
supposedly better for white right you
have more space and if she doesn't do
something tremendous dynamically then
you're just simply going to have an
advantage in the middle game a long-term
advantage in the middle game where do
you feel like you're taking over the
initiative when do you feel like you're
making and finding that
breakthrough uh I thought the Knight G4
idea like giving exchanging the Knight
to Bishop wasn't that great for her and
then after Bishop D4 I felt like at
least I have long-term you know slight
Advantage because my knight is way
better than the bishop and I played this
lines since uh I was a kid and I love it
for white so I felt very comfortable and
when she played C5 I was like okay it's
going to be a good day absolutely no
matter what because I really like you
like this type of for
wi yeah I do like it and then things
changed a little bit in uh the late
middle game uh phase and at this point
she gave you the queen but it wasn't
easy because maybe she could find some
sort of a blockade right how did you
feel about this how did you feel about
the assessment of this
position U before I played D5 I saw this
position and I felt like it should it
should be easier than than it was
actually when I was like evaluating I I
felt like this position should be better
for me but when I got the position I
started to think I'm like I don't have
much I felt like maybe I rushed into
this like C5 and it wasn't the most
precise way to play uh with white but
then uh I was happy with my position and
queen E1 trick I just got very likey
Queen uh B4 Queen H4 is coming if she
doesn't take on C5 then my idea is to
play B4 and she cannot take on A4
because of Queen A1 check that was my
idea yeah and then is if I'm pushing uh
B5 then I should be already winning so
it was kind of yeah at some point I
wanted to play Rook D1 and exchange the
uh Rooks and and then last minute I
decided not I feel like I should keep
the rots so it was a little bit uh
confusing for me but somehow it worked
out because she had time trouble and she
couldn't figure out how to uh defend the
position better I guess
uh well the pressure that he put on your
opponent paid off today congratulations
another important Victory will let you
go rest uh because you're still neck and
neck with Carissa this is a very tight
race yeah it looks F so
far nice uh congratulations beum once
again standings before we take a a break
just I mean because we're seeing a lot
of results today